hello and welcome to this video this is
around eight coverage of the candidates
tournament currently held in moscow yeah
round eight means it's a first round um
after the y after the break we get the
second the second game that every player
plays against each other half of the
tournament is already done yeah what
happened we have the game Aronian with
white against Giri the first to check
and we get a Queens gambit service
laughs okay that's a sharp line and
Bishop g5 played by Lev on that's the
most ambitious moving away III is the
alternative now black can decide mostly
between age 6 9 p-7 and DC for for the
BOD Vinick you replace age 6 this is the
middle of the road move it can be very
sharp if white now goes bishop HH four
or after Bishop f6 it's usually more of
a strategic battle yeah that was played
by Aronian I'm understandable I think he
also has played the sharp lines after
Bishop h4 like this this I'm sorry g5
first and then be five those am a very
very sharp but it's not really the kind
of position maybe you want if you lead
the tournament so he took plate Queen to
be three the interesting thing is that
all this has a history just weeks before
the tournament there was a game between
two players aronian gearing in Zurich
and they had exactly the same queen bee
three is an interesting move it prepares
them before if white goes efore here
immediately the problem is that black
will take and check and this is a bit
awkward now as white has to play yeah
some not very active retreating move
something like
like this yeah now let's say c5 black
has no problem here whatsoever this is
the idea of Queen to be three white
wants to go efore takes Knight eggs with
a tempo on the Queen without allowing
the check black goes DC form just
pre-empting this idea and playing 97
yeah now III is played yeah why not
eform eform black is very happily
answering with the movie 5 he likes to
see this pawn he actually so that these
will be traded and a pawn on d4 will go
of the board and if the pawn on d4
leaves it means that he will have good
squares for his pieces for example the
bishop or night can come to c5 this is
also why white played the more
restrained III now g6 interesting mad
like once sofiane care of this bishop
maybe bring the Queen back and then play
five this is standard nowadays in this
opening to go for a fee and keto not
play the Bishop to e7 or 26 and yeah now
94 Queen to e7 and 95 this is a still
following the earlier game aronian Giri
from Zurich 95 is an interesting idea
black you should never really take him
as this gives white to very promising
looking squares I mean it's not like
white wins but it simply whites at the
end why shouldn't a black shouldn't play
into that that much I played the check
this is a lot stronger tactics and King
to e2 yeah doesn't look very nice but
what else is stuck in d1 isn't any
better Bishop e7 back and that Bishop
has got nothing to do that on before
anymore and and here here's the novelty
aronia no place to move f3 doesn't look
very threatening yet played the lute f4
in there
I a game after which v6 King f2 bishop
to be seven Group D 1 rupee aid we
should be too yeah it is a slow game
where white has a little bit more space
and good nights and black has that long
term asset of the bishop here it is a
somewhat i think it's about equal this
position in the game Aronian played f3
and you can really um yeah wonder what
the big point of f three years i mean i
understand that you probably want to
play king f2 but that is also done with
therefore and why exactly is f3 being
played it's a bit mysterious hidden in
my book yeah um gearing goes for Luke to
g8 again not so obvious but he wants to
mainly play of 6 and kick that e5 Knight
away or this one if they are both both
as possible yeah 97 King tix yeah the
King takes because black still wants
this option v6 and Bishop to be 792 yeah
this was a bit more obvious but it also
doesn't lead to much black and ignore
the night but it can also take after
which let's say route takes be six then
bishop here or bishop a6 evening as
possible like this has a total equality
yeah 92 went back and again b6 Bishop e7
normal and white now set up this fyh for
thing put his pawns on dark squares with
this Bishop being on a light square
typical setup quite solid yeah the
likelihood of a draw he is very very
high I think and in the game we saw a
couple of trades and now after night see
for attending 95 gear we decided to go
into this position after which it is
opposite colored bishops yeah here there
are quite a number of ways to continue
but it always will be very very Jewish
Aronian actually tries a little
something here with this with this now
he could have played here and one upon
but the position here is also ultimately
superdry with Roxy 7 to come age right
that and we had to have this Yemen with
the white king black king being chased
around a little bit but there is no
objective threats and at the end they
agreed to a draw here yeah white is a
pawn up but he really doesn't have any
winning ideas for example if Garnett
said King to d2 rook to e3 and what is
not even able to move as pawns yeah it's
a typical opposite colored bishops
position where there is no forward both
those pawns cannot move at all heey
black probably um yeah might even win
the material back quite quite quickly
and he's very active so no problems at
all so somewhat unexcited draw here it's
not the most surprising result Aronian
is certainly okay with his co at the
moment he's not very hard-pressed to do
something crazy and geary is simply not
the kind of person who's doing anything
fancy with black so a draw was quite
likely him next came to check is to pile
of Arland let's go for that and we get
the Queens gambit declined with nat bd7
yeah this opening seems to be on some
main beam weapon here against deformed
in this tournament he has played this
already for the third time yet this with
black against aronian and black against
the giri in the last round and to pull
off place in the same way as giving
played Quincy to
and now Bishop before that was identical
yeah I know it's the new idea to power
some ideas to capture and play a three
quad them quite a logical continuation
yeah black now essentially has to TLC
three if you go back let's say to e7 you
go into a card spurred structure the
Queens gambit declined exchange
structure where you have gifted white
the move a 3 which is usually considered
to be quite useful here even Bishop f4
comes into consideration instead of
Bishop g5 which is also a little bit
better for white in comparison if you
can get this version in so we asked to
take on c3 to make some sense out of the
set up 94 temple castles yeah so what is
flex compensation yeah compensation I
mean for the bishop pair um he has got
the better development and good pieces
they had the night only four is strong
and black is already centralizing this
rook here after be three now it's an
interesting interesting moment now what
black should do I was discussing this a
little bit with with Joe Benjamin while
doing commentary for the ICC on Sunday
and I was suggesting this move as an
alternative to what Anna did and
unplayed the movie 6 which is also
probably the best one but I was
discussing this a little bit because
black with his better development tries
to open up the position which is a
little bit counterintuitive maybe if you
look at this visual pay issue yeah with
the bishop pair you want to open the
position is wide so why would black open
the position they have it he's got the
better development this is an
interesting and interesting
contradictory problem here we had
something similar discussed some rounds
ago for the game
I think silly aronian yeah c5 is
interesting black tries to open it up
but I'm not quite sure how good it is if
white ECM and Knight takes the
development is really very okay but it's
still not quite clear how good it is I
mean after Bishop b2 maybe Bishop d7
rook c8 comes but the question is in
general after c5 of white should take in
the first place it's maybe better and to
just just develop him yeah interesting
Queen a5 check now a couple of options I
think c5 is interesting alternative but
c6 isn't bad at all yeah Bishop d3 all
this is I guess kind of normal looking
this is also a reason why black has no
problems here he gets his Bishop to f5
and from there he can engineer this
trading medusa quite comfortably with
those bishops traded black shouldn't be
afraid anymore of any minority attack on
the queenside now playing with before
would actually be a pretty bad idea for
example well this is what black plate
and now am 3 by 2 part of a move like B
form is an entirely wrong idea here as
the c-4 square has been severely
weakened and white is not getting
anything like a 45 year with black
controlling the square so reliably this
would just help black topology move f3
is a lot better he wants to get
something going in the center a 4 that's
a good one trying to maybe activate the
bishop and black activates is nights
like this yeah I think black has a
rather comfortable position here I'm
given the choice I probably rather be
black here but its overall still pretty
equal yeah to pile of now plays a very
yet he plays the move that has to be um
considered carefully he played Knight to
f4 getting rid of that is 69 it worsens
his pawn structure and gives black
basically an extra porn here on the
queenside it's four against three and
the wider double porn doesn't react by
her that much confidence plus we get
trades on the year file I think he was
it was clear to him that he has to
suffer a little bit in this position but
should ultimately manage to draw not a
very great prospect but he's simply not
in good shape in this event again here
not getting an interesting position at
all with white yeah so those rooks got
traded and in this position only black
can be better and can try something yeah
black can set up the position easily in
a way that the white Bishop is never
going to attack it again if you go a six
and some at some moment for example and
even there seven points / / light square
and whites Bishop is not ever ever ever
ever taking opponent um still it's very
difficult to make any headway and we can
fast forward a little bit and see what
happened aren't ultimately it's a long
shuffle and push this this age form yeah
understandable decision you want to
probably in on a good day you get h3 end
and this pawn would be very very helpful
in cooperation with the black queen on
the other hand it also can be can be
weak one I'm issue here that we
shouldn't forget us we tend to easily
identify
that the white Bishop isn't looking so
great yeah we see immediately it looks
at his own pawns so that Bishop isn't
great agreed but there's still one issue
the Black Knight what so isn't that
great and this is the thing yeah you
very easily see that the bishop is not
good but the night here it doesn't help
much either especially a little bit
later like here oops I'm sorry a little
bit a little bit later here we see that
after Queen III black cannot avoid
really the Queen trade yeah if black is
keeping the Queen's on then it might
even be white aspetta h3 is preventing
the push here and Queen to e7 is coming
note how bad this nidus and the night
cannot go anywhere and black now public
it's already a little bit too late now
to try to regroup here as queen is
heaven is going to pick up this pawn or
lead to other trouble I can do this but
as to give up that yeah at the end it's
just one thing that black and we have to
trade and now 926 it is some exactly
this line now that leads to a draw
anything else would lead into trouble
for both sides so um yeah King here I
mean if black is not playing 96 then
King edge 3 we will pick up the porn so
this has to be done and now g5 yeah it
here and white went f5 which is the best
move there is no upside in taking yeah
this this and then like continue here
and this really absolutely no idea how
white could ever win this position there
are three Pawn is pretty it's pretty bad
doesn't really contribute much and the
black has a potential c5 so this is not
a good idea the alternative f5 is a lot
better because here black has to play
night at four
and this is a safe draw black should not
retreat as after f form he's into
trouble yeah maybe he saves it but it's
absolutely no reason to get into that
only white can be better than this
position so the check after white has to
take pawn takes NTM after King g2 they
agree to a draw after King age for black
in wins with c5 so this was a mandatory
yet here there's absolutely no way
forward if black is getting too fancy
with this King and try to invade somehow
then g5 and the f1 will run so this is a
um yeah this is an important factor of
the position and in general we would
have it have something where both sides
handsome some kind of some kind of
quandary you cannot really do anything
active you have both sides here we'll
just going to stay and do nothing any
kind of activity is bound to is bound to
backfire I mean white can probably take
here without losing but there's also no
upside to that so a draw in this game I
think Arnold is probably quite ok with
the draw and to paula is basically out
of the event with this current score so
is we have tried to try to still play
well of course but it doesn't really
matter to him that much anymore in terms
of a qualification spot yeah now let's
look at the two most interesting games
of the round you just start with swidler
coyoacán and see what happens there
crack in one of the two co-leaders and
swidler on a minus one score so yes will
I had missed many many good
opportunities in the event he should be
on a plus corner on my desk or if you
just look at the games and then CEO came
he could have won that one he could have
won this one why is the owner minus cone
yeah so it
doesn't help you need to win the games
just having good position good positions
is not enough okay let's have a look at
this Villa kayaking in English opening
sweet let's playing c4 on this event not
really going with usually for repertoire
and we follow a well-known line that has
been tested over the last iron of 3040
years the most famous game with this is
them I think the second match game it
was of the power of cop of match in 1987
played in sevilla spain um when cup of
plate after this ruki aid at f3 a cup of
plata at the time sensational move III
it was never played before they had been
games with the capture on a three but
III it was a new idea that Karpov had
prepared um form actually I think for
cautionary for the 1978 match but never
got to got around to playing it and then
he could use it here against them
against Kasparov yeah this is a plate
also here in this game and these three
was also kasparov's reply um yeah why
does not want to take that pawn this
pawn structure is just a bit too ugly
yep if um yeah if you want to see
something real funny you can look at
this and 94th of course atrocious but it
just oops it just is just a funny
picture yeah why does a pawn up I hope
he's happy with it no of course why Pope
lady three anyway this is a stronger
move d take c3 is not that bad but after
age six you should go to h3 yeah well d3
is better anyway yeah keeping this
Center fluid without a double porn yeah
black goes d5 he has to develop somehow
and now Queen to a four that's an
interesting move it in 10
to recapture on C form with the Queen if
black now would do that Queen takes
white is actually in very good shape
that f7 porn is under fire and you don't
have a very convenient move to cover it
I mean something like this for example
it's just pretty awful White has the
better Center and he's got 22 bishops
here black needs to be very very careful
here that those long-term assets don't
become too dominant um played age six
cd59 takes and 94 so what God is neither
round to that very very good square this
is not a new position that has been has
been played and for example in some
correspondence games and certainly it
should have been part of both players
preparation to some extent kayaking
played really quickly so it's very clear
that you still knew what was going on f5
and 95 what else yeah now f4 is play
that's probably the sharpest move trying
to expand you on the King side one idea
is that this Bishop on g2 is looking
really really bad it doesn't have any
scope and we will see later that this
will become even more pronounced yeah
white played Bishop b2 but looks very
normal rugby 8 yahoo p8 might look a
little bit mysterious but black needs to
organize this position somehow it's not
so easy to do that what move do you want
to play here the idea can be a for white
to play em to pay c4 here one two
advanced the whole Center c4 and d4 we
see that later yeah another droopy eight
was played it also might involve this
idea which is very double-edged but it
can be part of the agenda yes you for
now by base Midler this is the first new
move by the way and some correspondence
game 19 for was played yeah see form
night dg7 the problem or the drawback
let's say of that c4 move is that it
Ricans the d4 square the white Bishop
won't be too as a fantastic diagonal but
black has currently control over that
square if white gains control over
deform and can get something going on
that long diagonal he would have an
excellent position it's a very
double-edged situation with those III
and f4 pawns limiting wide on the King
side and limiting the bishop on you too
but as I said long-term Yasim has many
assets swidler now plays a very very um
double-edged move he is definitely i'm
afraid that black manages to get in
Knight to f5 and night to d4 indeed this
is a scary idea for white but it's not
clear if his rep if his recipe is the
right one he went with the very radical
move g4 just covering that square but
note this is one of the most stupid
looking bishops ever not ever ask them
if they're they're worse but it is not
looking very good yeah that bishop is
not having any any prospects if black
here would manage to play g5 and
completely shut this Bishop down without
getting killed I mean for example here
some something like g5 doesn't make any
sense because 94 f6 is deadly but if you
can long-term keep that Bishop here with
the pawn being on g4 this is just an
in-car sir
in peace so a very risky decision here
by bus villa yeah p 6 and the Bishop to
e6 or that is I think very very logical
now Black is ready to play 94 it might
cost the a7 porn but it's just too
important to block that diagonal um
spitless approach to this now is
probably not good he plays the move g
fire and we really wants to like open up
things there on the on the King side
however there's the drawback and a
drawback that kayaking is not not
showing he played age five in the game
but he could have taken this pawn
instead this would have been strong
simply for one reason wyd cannot
recapture after night f5 and flex
position is excellent note that he can
easily neglect that night because after
this and green takes like is just
winning this is too bad here for white
king edge one for example there's 93
already and after the capture chang this
is not ending well so what is why it's
supposed to do if he cannot take c6 yeah
he can go back to you form but then
black happily jumps into d4 and has a
absolutely great position here yeah he's
blocking the b2 bishop and queen h4 is
just around the corner with a big attack
this is great this is really a great
position um yeah it's not clear to me
what white should have done after the
capture maybe just neglect all of that
and just play loop d1 trying to push the
form yeah I've it now again 94 is
happening and something
like this this may be this in Bishop d7
is just a good position for black now
he's gotten rid of that strong Bishop on
b2 and white situation on them on the
King side here with this Bishop still
doesn't look good in the game however h5
was played and I think after that the
worst is probably over for white rook t1
trying to play d4 it's prevented that's
a lie to grab the pawn yeah I think you
can do that it's not it's not a bad
decision you might as well have a pawn
for your for your yeah that's a
difficult to play position I am not sure
how bad this is objectively speaking but
yeah it doesn't hurt to take that porn
queen to d7 covers the c7 and Queen back
the Queen had to go back you cannot stay
there forever and risk the getting
trapped so H 4 and now sometimes h3 is
an idea Queen c3 intending d4 again and
now hbu should have five back I ockendon
so that's a good move it looks at this
at this night makes it difficult to
advance so easily with a form that was
not the only move black also had 96 for
example which was a no one goes okay
yeah well this happened and now a very
interesting move pass with light plays
age three and this looks a little bit
like some kind of baiting move yeah
please take that pawn yeah it looks
really strange that why does offering
offering this porn but gap he probably
was afraid that h3 from black was even
was universe
yeah so it's a bait move in a way so
should black take that bait or not
probably he shouldn't but in the game he
did let's have a look um and what
happens if he does not take the
alternative the main alternative was
Knight to c6 the idea is simply to put
that night on that fantastic square and
let the white Bishop look yea rather
stupid on g2 this move was probably
rather strong their key ideas that now d
form which is the only move that really
ya could question this decision that
this is not so great because now you
take and this is a different thing
because after deform that night is not
so stable anymore and black has ideas of
just taking here on you for maybe with
the bishop or I was a wrong arrow maybe
you're going with the bishop and then
take and you have such odds really have
phone attack if why cause d5 then 95 is
good yeah here and it's really
questionable if white is going to
survive here for example line like this
is spectacular and pretty strong yeah
this is that check your winning position
for black J quite nice um okay not
forced not forced but it seems that
knight c6 was a good reply as deform is
not helping white that much and in other
cases if white plays some some some slow
move who I know that one then 94 is just
yeah it's no fun yeah Bishop back here
or what end and
no maybe this to make the Queen mobile
again and a black physician is fantastic
he is a pawn down but it's just a great
great initiative and whites pieces look
weird especially if one looks weird yeah
he took that porn immediately and I
think I didn't see the press conference
I think what happened to ukiah can
simply overlooked swithers reply 25
attacking the f4 porn and now if you
don't want to lose that um you more or
less have to do this and after that
Queen d5 the Queen's get raided and
whites problem with this mission is not
as terrible anymore as he's got King up
and Bishop h3 in some cases to trade off
that dummy bishop you shouldn't forget
that wide also has a pretty strong night
there on e4 it's not like or pieces of
badges that the bishop is is a problem
the position I think now is roughly
equal however a little bit later I think
most of those moves are kind of kind of
obvious in a way of at least easy to
understand what they do yeah black is
finding up on that a porn and white
tries to break through in the center
where it's got this potential paso arm
chances to open up the position for him
in a favorable way yeah up to this point
I think that was all well played and the
position is around equal about equal
White's a DM he is to play the move d6
to dislodge that pawn get this pawn and
then continue to play against that new
pawn on d6 here um kayaking reacts in a
wrong way which was very difficult to
see and play the clock times he are not
they didn't have much time left he
played this and this leads into some
trouble after d6 takes and rook takes we
already see that this is looking kind of
awkward and black really um yeah now has
no big choice he has to step out of this
and go at to age 59 took 26 and this
rook came over to look at the airport
yeah black ism yeah black is on the
ropes here after would be five he has to
defend very precisely and ya didn't
didn't manage she played knight c6 the
computer wants to play the route to a
six but it probably both um is it's
tough to very tough to defend um now
White has options he can't play move
like Knight to f5 keep a big advantage
or play the move that swidler place
which is believed to be the best one by
the engines g6 check what's the point
yeah black basically has to grab the
pawn and now rook c1 all of a sudden
that Lucas switching over and we
immediately see that this position must
be critical for black the rook is coming
in with check and all of black spots on
so our weakish I mean especially those
three of course III III will all only
form and FY gets taken yeah so what has
an attack on the king and at the same
time tries to win no other pawns very
difficult to react to that now this is
all pretty logical looking i guess and
white is picking up things and now the
first critical moment of the remaining
game that same here rook takes f4 was
very strong taking this pawn first not
taking the porn age for which is what's
villa did
if you take on f4 with the rook here a
situation should be pretty
straightforward the problem is that
black has no good move if it takes e to
then-rookie for is a good idea attacking
this and just evened out the app pick up
pawns you can pick III up I probably h4
out for two pawns this should win sweet
let's move also should win but it's a
little bit more complicated now g6
reform night back to f8 the other night
is a good defender on f8 but it served
wouldn't have helped if white now place
the right continuation he has to find
the move rookie 5 now this is still
strong it intends to play rook to e7 in
case of black capturing on a two so for
example this there is rookie 7g cigs
look f1 and white is winning because
black can also not afford to take here
it's 98 is a pretty straightforward win
threatening Knight f6 with made or
threatening route g7 with me to come
yeah rookie 5 was a pretty um clear and
clean when he took this pawn however and
now after Luke a two white has to be
absolutely precise to preserve winning
ideas what he should have done now is
night f5 looks a bit weird to get into
that that self fork but it's the only
way to do that after this and then route
gt5 white still retains winning
prospects not quite sure how much of a
chance it is but you can definitely
continue something like this is done is
the the main continuation white will win
their pawn and enjoys this extra porn
while black
is still yeah a little bit boxed in in
the corner the engine just says wide
winds fled out but I'm still a little
bit I mean it's not a super easy
technical task to win this position as
you are down to two against one points
and there's always this likelihood that
you get some ending just with the bear
piece that you cannot win so what
happened in the game this happened and
now g6 and this is not add all good
anymore yeah this check looks huge but
what's the point it's nowhere it just
leads nowhere there's no check on age 7
and what is why the rook now doing hmm
very tough very tough c5 okay I'm taking
this and it's equal material all of a
sudden yeah so this chick didn't really
help this is what's villa did and
actually already offered the drawer
probably been very frustrated about the
whole turn of events I think he later
said that he believed to be much much
worse at one point maybe yeah maybe but
he also was yeah lot better and winning
he around here with some precise mcfly
brookie fire for example the game could
have been over and this would have been
a huge result for the overall tournament
with kayaking dropping down to +1 sweda
coming back to fifty percent and maybe
getting back into the race again but
here's some continuing to to play well
up to a certain point and then screw up
and a hugely favorable position so a
very disappointing result for the
seven-time Russian champion dear Peter
Svidler um okay let's look at the fourth
game of this round and the most
anticipated one maybe Caruana with wide
against Nakamura a very interesting
matchup
the camera was on a minus one score yeah
after his win against Apollo so with the
second win in a row he could get back
into contention ready a 50-percent after
eight rounds is not hopeless and kawana
is sitting there with them seven drawers
and also definitely would like to win
again he had his chances earlier in the
vent but didn't score so we get a Berlin
with d3 and before you fell asleep fall
asleep that game will get very
interesting ok takes on c6 night BTW to
in many cases white castles early but
that's not happening here because whites
idea is not to play with short castles
but actually with castling long very
interesting plan we have seen this in in
earlier games earlier this year for
example there was a game pinned between
the Chinese some hope by he and David
navara from the Czech Republic which
went exactly like this when tiem up to
this position and hereby he played the
move h4 later age 5 and then he Castle
short corona is trying something similar
he castles long immediately not using
the pawns um this is definitely a much
more interesting way to play against
them Berlin then to play them with some
yeah playing some ending or some very
very slow maneuvering position here both
sides will try to get at each other's
King um interesting and I think also
pretty pretty good plan yeah and neck
are unknown place and according to the
tournament situation in a way choosing
the most direct most aggressive movie
Ghost be five and a five just pushing
the pawns
you can argue if you look at the further
course of the game that may be a move
like c5 also would have been interesting
the idea is to clamp down on that square
and potentially reroute the night like
that it's a very strategically focused
approach and not so much um trying to
find a quick counter-attack towards what
white will be doing on the King side it
looks a bit slow but on the other hand
blacks position around the king also is
not weakened yet he has got all
everything back here so why shouldn't
have like a winning attack automatically
on the King side so this is an option
definitely just try to be strategic and
put a night here okay be five and a five
Knight to f5 good attacking square and
now the next move with them once you see
it or once you see that the consequences
um is strong but it's not maybe that
obvious he goes Bishop g5 okay f6 is the
most normal move ever and also probably
the best one I know karana just dropped
back to e3 and what is the point now of
this of this strange pendulum buy them
by the bishop the point is that f6 is a
move that quite often actually fits into
blacks plans long-term cover a five so
that you can reroute those two pieces
but the main drawback is something
different here white has cassard long
and this means that g45 oops g45 now
becomes a very serious option attacking
that f6 pawn and breaking open the G
file a lot quicker then it would be
possible without the pawn being on f6
95 g-form there should be six and key to
be one yeah white had to take care of
that h2porn cannot give it away yeah and
nakamura goes before no this is clear we
want to go for this this checkmating
race and certainly a position that both
players from the general type of
position wanted to have they wanted a
fight and they they got a fight the
question is however how good is it for
black after g5 to be honest I think um
why does probably just quicker in this
attack you can definitely argue about
blacks um best defense now he played
them yet the most aggressive reply I
think after that black definitely is in
some issues and some trouble maybe he
should play something like King edge
ages step of the G file and being ready
to answer GTX with G takes I mean what I
think is also better here but it's not
it's not a totally clear cut affair in
the game be three was played and corona
reacts to that and very cool headed way
just rook h2g one just allow black to
take yeah so this is what you did yeah
zebra took that porn it's really not so
easy to open lines there for black yeah
um for example if you try check this for
example and queen takes there's simply
no good follow up yeah where's the night
going you can try something something
funny but white is just attacking
himself he's not even contemplating
taking that night after after this black
has to be quick he cannot yeah waste
lots of time the engine
suggest as the best defensive move g6
this is a lot of movie you love to play
yeah playing a pawn move on that side
where the other guys attacking you but
maybe you have to do it just to slow
down the hole cause of action a little
bit now there is no clear-cut way for
white forward now he can try something
like this check and then maybe a three
keeping things closed note that here
Bishop b3 is not a good idea actually
this is a play looper ta black shouldn't
take care because of night Jess out
that's the idea yeah this is a
completely em yack really untie the
unclear type of position I mean unclear
as wrong I think why it's better but it
just is that's very messy so I'm trying
to say maybe this is what black should
have should have gone from he took here
and now King a one and here it's
actually already difficult to find
anything that is playable now I'm the
move g6 is not that great anymore white
can reply with just taking on f6 or
playing this funny move yeah directly
trying to break through after night
takes check check no D take c5 is also
pretty yeah pretty bad for black I
really think it's it's tough to to get
to still get a playable position maybe
it's not possible anymore which casts
some doubt on that d505 plan probably it
wasn't that great but I completely
understand why nakamura played like that
I mean it's not it's not looking that
bad in the first place and it's also
exactly the
end of game that he needed I needed to
win this game okay Luke a one again
sorry King a one what did black play he
ultimately decided to take the night
again this is not what you left to do
because after taking now white gets this
potential dream square for the night you
tried a three yeah opening going for
counter play King h8 is what the engine
suggest just to try to hold on but after
that white is a lot better probably with
night to h4 but also with night 2 D 2
which is what I prefer why I just would
get this fantastic square for ESPYs yeah
that was played and just this to keep
everything closer yeah night a six by
nakamura this is still an interesting
idea he tries to maybe go here white now
has to be a little bit careful at least
the move 92 for example it's not a great
idea because of e4 which at least
irritates white quite a bit he cannot
take this for example as rookie for
takes Jack and we should check leads to
a way I win for black and yeah this is
chang pretty bad so what did Kara wanna
do found a strong move c3 the computer
oops that was the wrong button the
computer actually wants to play d4 like
that even more but c3 is perfectly good
it covers all the critical squares be
form and also d4 why does some is having
a winning position here Bishop f8 and
now the night comes around ook g3 is
again as a strong move black now cannot
take on d3 I mean okay it loses just as
the game continuation losses but this is
some pretty simple and not
putting up much pressure here bishop age
67 the size of IDM get this is what you
played and now just keep it simple take
that pawn and have the rook here on h3
in a menacing position Bishop b5 and d4
that was the last interesting moment
here Queen to h5 which looks completely
obvious it's not so good because of the
CAPTCHA here after Knight takes Queen D
for black is actually all right that
counter threat of Queen takes c3 is so
awful that you have to give a perpetual
why tries to cover this there's rookie
one yeah and now White has to give a
perpetual otherwise you probably even
lose but this is also not necessary at
all he just played the move d for simple
and strong attacking that Bishop it went
back and looked you one now All Whites
pieces are attacking legs king and white
has extra material plus a good night
just King takes to form 325 and after
see for now nakamura resigned the game
so we got a winner in that American duel
a very important game which basically
ends the tournament for number 1 minus
two after eight rounds is impossible to
come back from but it opens up the path
for kawana for sure he's now on +1 after
these eight rounds and well plus one is
good yeah it's just have a point behind
the two tournament leaders and the same
scores vishy anand s so everything is
possible yet or still for Caruana I
think it was a good interesting round
with two very tense games the two other
games weren't that exciting but I think
the
dual and the Russian one they both
really held up to expectations or beyond
that I hope you enjoyed the coverage of
of this eighth round the round nine
video is just around the corner thanks
for watching guys